welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question it's a show that gives
you too much information about things
like the terrifying real world threat so
we gotta brace ourselves with with some
chapstick and they almost made it into
our cinematic universes and I don't
wanna get sick what's scary about that
is cinematic universes or the universe
that Philip and I prefer to put all of
our time and effort in rather than the
real world so this is really threatening
so we're gonna talk about some things
that were removed from Marvel Cinematic
Universe and other universes for being
too controversial and I'm Phillip milena
and I'm Erik Voss and we're here for you
because you're your fantasy worlds are
just as important as the real world so
Philip our big question today is this
report that the Falcon the Winter
Soldier actually is going through
reshoots serious reshoots because the
first couple episodes of their season
dealt with a storyline about a disease
outbreak that was too similar to the
corona virus threat right the metallo
virus it very taken working so I think I
think we have to ask what was the deal
with this coronavirus storyline was it
too controversial really did it deserve
being cut from this show finding out
exactly what the details are I tried I
got a little bit actually but then it
was in spoiler territory so I didn't
want to search all that past too much
but no we don't know exactly what it was
but we can assess whether or not they
should have cut this thing basically by
looking at other storylines that should
have been cut in the past based on the
reaction that people gave it when it
came out usually too soon really quick I
want to clarify a couple of things that
this is not a list of controversial
stories period right it's not the
hashtag twincest video that you guys are
waiting for it at some point one day one
day disgusting terrible storyline it's
also not a list of just like things that
are difficult to talk about like Oh a
9/11 story it's like well some of these
things you know need to reflect the real
world that's what keeps them interesting
this is when people got really mad at
comics for doing a story they probably
shouldn't have done at that moment I
don't necessarily think that people
should have always gotten mad on that
too but you'll see that as we go okay so
ultimately what we're actually assessing
is should they have removed these things
like my favorite thing that got removed
in the recent past the me to movement
making them take a scene out of Toy
Story 2 where stinky Pete is like doing
a sink out stroke with these two hot
barbi twins where he's like I can put
you in the next toy story movie if you
know you I get something out of it
yeah they knew it was wrong when they
did it you know I'm sure I could get you
a part in Toy Story sweetie I'm sorry
but we've had these are things they did
not get rid of you ready okay let's do
it let's do a countdown style least two
most offensive and then later we'll see
where carnivai are sort of fitted all
right so first one it's kind of a
surprise but you have to see it in the
context of its time in the nineteen
forties actually specifically in 1940
famously Captain America number one the
cover do you remember it was like a
Hitler thing right yes it's Captain
America beat Hitler and they represent
MC right II like punched Hitler's movie
yes so was their propaganda that's a
propaganda show so in the comic
storyline think about you're like well
why is that offensive punching Hitler
this is 1940 specifically before the US
has entered the war with Hitler it's
just a kind of foreign dictator now is
before we knew yeah everything everybody
was pro-hitler until the note that's not
true but the reason I it's included on
this list is because there was an
outrage by layton Nazi sympathizers who
were like trying to beg hey you guys are
all overreacting the stories have been
greatly exaggerated he's a good friend
of mine you know but obviously he does
have a little bit of problems but
otherwise like he's pretty good there
were a lot of American Nazi sympathizers
later more before before we officially
entered the war people weren't
necessarily against Hitler yeah and so
Captain America punching Hitler resulted
in a bunch of death threats to the
creators I at Marvel Comics at the time
so people actually really mad I think
though you know what I'm gonna say I
don't like Hitler so I'm okay with that
no it's okay and I never liked Hitler I
like to think at the time both of us
would be very anti Hitler I like to
think who knows what I would have been
like in the 40 right next down so that's
not terribly offensive weirdly kind of
was offensive some people then this one
is from 2010 it's pretty recent actually
and I never remember law and order was
every week was doing like ripped from
the headlines Wow TV's longest-running
and drama returns with an explosive
ripped from the headlines case well that
started to spill into comics so actually
there a lot of comics around 2010 that
are all ripped from the headlines and
this specifically you remember the h1n1
swine flu would you or did he dress this
one swine flu and you know what you're
next on my station zero it was a oh yeah
yeah we did that thing with that porky
yeah well I never saw Porky's and I
thought it was involved bestiality with
the pig and they turned that into a
black me rip sewed Porky's that's a
really funny like Marisa so the swine
flu they just like even though it was
like this this real flu very similar
what's going on right now they did go
ahead and make a storyline about aging X
and why I doesn't whine flu but like
what's offensive about and why people
are upset is it's just like kind of deep
hours some mutants and only mutants can
get in like this is actually kind of a
big deal but ultimately I'm gonna say
not terribly offensive yeah it's it's
still it's enough that people complain
they get you can assume everything on
this list death threats were sent right
cuz they did I mean doesn't take much to
get a death threat yeah sometimes we
just say mispronounced an of the sings
in this box yeah there's a lot of knives
and throwing stars in there yeah but I
mean it's wine flu some people died from
it so you can imagine at the time some
people bein like you shouldn't be
pulling this from the headlines yeah
superhero storyline exactly I especially
where like wasn't a huge tragedy there's
a kind of a lighter thing up next number
three is again it's Captain America but
also now from 2010 ripped from the
headlines era Captain America him Falcon
days go undercover in what they're
calling like this intense racist redneck
movement that it's like all these evil
bad guys but when they portrayed what
the mob of them I was are at a rally it
was literally just the Tea Party
movement they even used the exact signs
from pictures of tea party protesters
which politics wise that's thirty
percent of the country agrees with those
politics and then they're reading that
Captain America equates them with the
Nazis literally there's a guy who was
holding that sign it ended up in that
comic as himself and Captain America's
like worse enemy at the time eventually
weird
it's Captain America's in support of
these people but that's a complicated
story I mean some of the Tea Partiers
did have super racist signs but it's
basically saying all of them are
deplorable and as we know like you can't
paint them all with them some of them
have political arguments or economic
arguments one of the signs of something
like teabag the libs before they to bag
America or something and it made it into
the comic directly that is something we
should do everyone would benefit for
being team one tea bagging is always bad
it's soothing I have a positive
association with tea bagging yeah what
else does it mean other than just
drinking tea then dipping your scrotum
into hot water right that's yeah sounds
good to me
I think that one actually does slightly
cross the line in that it just took
real-world sentiments of fairly normal
it misunderstands real-world sentiments
kind of like with h1n1 things don't
really get it what's interesting about
this one though is they had to reprint
that comic now changing all the signs
out to be Occupy Wall Street I know so
now we're starting to get like a little
more fun so at least some amount of
people that consider themselves tea
partiers are offended by that 2003
pretty much everybody can be offended by
this one I 2003 is a very specific time
in our history where post 9/11 were Iraq
war era kind of thing rights right so
much stuff was on the radio yeah I know
constantly my mom spaghetti was
everywhere and also everywhere the idea
of jihad right what better way to
exploit that than the x-men going on
literally what's called their holy war
the ex my holy war comic here's the
thing okay maybe the x-men are gonna go
deal with al-qaeda or something yeah
fine yeah
right yeah I know it has nothing to do
with that it's the phrase holy war but
it's about Nightcrawler who's a devout
Catholic he's training to be a priest at
the sign and then this storyline reveals
no he's not he's secretly part of a cult
and they're crazy and he's gonna be the
new pope and they start crucifying
people in front of the x-men
achievements oh this is the holy war
that they're on it kind of sounds like a
Dan Brown book right like it's oh hell
yeah that actually looked annoyed heresy
to take over the the papacy Yeah right
wasn't that angels and demons that the
young Pope yeah
yeah in the new pope which i realize
it's the same show yeah yeah it is the
same show yeah you have one Pope two
popes
young Pope's new pope oh that's a good
when he was working for the Catholic
Church that's a good dr. Seuss
so got more offensive and then I'm just
gonna ticket I definitely you know
didn't go to everything they could have
on this list but this one really kind of
this is our number one most
controversial should have never done
this story story and it is surprising
how many were similar to this but all
this could be one specific one it's from
the 80s know those strangers think kids
are the characters name that they have
this is a DC comic is extraño which
could be translated to queer okay he's
the first openly gay DC superhero and he
shows it to you as much as he can he
wears women's jewelry he calls himself
auntie for some reason and he says a lot
of like listen honey when he's saving
someone
but that's not the part that put it on
the list actually what it's the part
where extraño contracts HIV and that's
not the worst part
because people were getting it in the
80s it's the way he gets it is from an
AIDS vampire named hemoglobin what what
excuse me
hemo-goblin oh I mean it's a pretty good
pun you could imagine something like 80s
right or be like wait a minute if I just
move the let my dyslexia baby Nancy I
came up with an AIDS vampire it's gonna
fix everything she's like don't pretend
like I'm your wife I know you and that
man across the street yeah I'm putting
it in the art it's researched I know you
understand me so he can't get a
physically from AIDS and Peyer as what's
happened in the eighties right there was
a lot of vampires and they were all gay
right
so not a stereotype here's here's the
thing so that's like about as offensive
as you can get in at the time people did
acknowledge like holy crap this is so
bad but I'm gonna say again kind of like
I was saying earlier it's not the
subject matter that makes it
they can't do this it's the approach
right it's an AIDS vampire or something
so I'm gonna give Marvel some credit
just you know that's the end of the
offensive stuff but the same concept
because AIDS was such a big epidemic it
was a virus that people were very
worried about Marvel a few years later
son 92 with an alpha flight story this
is one where they had been implying
North Star with gay for a long time but
they wouldn't really go into it
North Star decides to adopt a baby who
has AIDS who is dying and then the baby
dies and North Star decides that this is
the the moment that he should come out
and he officially comes out as gay and
it's kind of just like this intense kind
of dramatic storyline that also has you
know heroes and villains and whoa yeah
in it but there's no like AIDS vampire
yeah yeah sounds like plays in the
history of gay people being like
portrayed as villains or a lot of
villains being kind of effeminate or gay
or a coded yeah and so the fact that you
would use that and use like the whole
blood transfusion thing it's just kind
of sick so the idea that to cover this
story in this slightly more nuanced way
still was hated at the time and was
covered very negatively but nowhere near
as bad as explained yo and nature wolf
and then I'll even remind you we were
talking about this at the same time
Captain Planet was dealing sowed and I
told this to like my sister one point
she's like you imagine that that was
never episode of Captain Planet
Gavan planet super progressive show from
the early 90s and in late 80s whenever
that ran for that like I can't got gay
and that kid was me there was a kid who
had AIDS and was being bullied and like
you know ostracize Captain Planet a step
in and be like look this is something
that a lot of people just have to deal
with fine together to bring Captain
Planet to Omaha to give a lecture to but
I don't think he did any actual like
comic like he just like had a nice
empathetic conversation with people
about how we shouldn't demonize people
for their diseases or illnesses yeah I
do remember this episode but to be fair
because you've talked about that a
number of times say it's David material
though it is possible a Mew had
shouldn't really trust any of like my
memories I had a dream I got gay
and it made me straight isn't that what
scared straight it's so with all these
storylines that had to be like changed
or reversed like where does coronavirus
right so and this is I think gonna be a
discussion with you here because you can
see that people's outrage can be
ridiculous right yes be kind of stupid
I'll say my position on the corona virus
is I'm Pro corona virus is that I think
right now because people are dying
literally today people will die from the
corona virus and if you're watching this
in the future you know that most of us
have but now I but people are dying then
yes if the storyline on the show is
people are catching this virus and dying
then yes I think that's that's what
we're going for escapism we don't need
to read it my caveat is if it's actually
like a Marvel a virus or something like
I was talking to you about the
possibility what if it's a nanovirus and
it's actually the Ultron virus or
something right it's like you know this
kind of cool sci-fi concept then hell
yeah do it yeah who cares do it I just
don't know which one it is yeah I think
even if like say coronavirus kind of
peaked and then subsided and then like a
couple months later the season comes out
and they know what happened with it I
think it'd be okay to do the problem is
is just like we don't know how bad it's
gonna get and you can imagine like
Disney being like this could be like a
really horrible pandemic and we don't
want our show to come out in the midst
of like people afraid to leave their
homes cities quarantined all over the
world so you can man just probably just
like some calculus by the show trying to
prognosticate
where it's gonna go so we're just where
do you land on it should they cancel
this thing or no I think I can imagine
being a producer on that show worried
about how that it's gonna get and if
it's if you're able to switch it out for
something that's not specific to a
disease outbreak that's where people
coughing sneezing wearing medical masks
and showing like third world countries
that are going to hell as a result of
like the Ebola style panic yeah maybe
maybe change it especially you have
Disney money you can reshoot a whole
face yeah take it back into the workshop
take or whatever you want to make it
better give it back to us now
follow-up question which of these
stories is your favorite that you're the
biggest fan of you know what I'd love
that x-men holy war storyline I think
that sounds kind of interesting of like
it's also garbage like it's just like
think of it I mean I don't want to
offend anyone in their like religious
politics but like the history of the
Catholic Church at one point was just
like three different cults deciding
which Pope had like the biggest army and
that became the new pope of like history
so like kind of reminding people of like
the history of all these world religions
that they're all just kind of like
whichever group is the most impassioned
to believe hers it's to win the day
that's probably not where they were
going but just like if some of the
writers took that big picture
perspective when they're writing and I
think that's interesting you could work
in propaganda and marketing because you
just I already do you just rephrased
holy war as religious politics yes holy
war that's going up just your eyebrow
just goes up involuntarily yes it does
so let's move on to our next question
are you trying to tell me I I think I'm
still figuring that out what do you want
me to say that's it they should have
done it yeah this shoulda come maybe
yeah Bucky thinks we should have done it
look at him he's so mad at Disney for
cutting this the corona virus stinky he
wasn't looking like that when I through
before hit look like they're in a
hospital there and they're mad yeah
they're been quarantined it's the real
question is is our thumbnail too
offensive for this episode you've
already decided that before watching
more than 30 seconds of this video
thanks for those comments by the way
before we move on to some other things
that we want to answer we just want to
remind everyone that currently really
the hottest place to be in like the
realm of new rock stars land is there
discord
oh I thought you're gonna say a club in
New York Times discord has everything
under siege
it has spoiler channels MCU diba to
teens teens cheaters big fan of teens
all these we were there it was three
separate for him he also is a fan of the
person with the username team the reason
why we keep talking about this is like
we didn't intend for like our discord we
just wanted to offer something that we
could like connect with people on like a
different platform and we're [ __ ]
loving it
come like this amazing group
conversation on it at the gym now yep
and when I'm driving and swerving yeah
you guys are giving us such an
interesting run for our money with these
topics in this question and and now
they're putting big questions in there
and then they're answering them for us
sometimes but we came up with this new
idea that people are gonna start playing
rogue theory yes on there and be awarded
point to kind of have like simulated
okay so we're gonna like try to come up
with like new different like digital
ways that we can connect with people
because we can't touch people anymore
cuz the coronavirus answer yeah the way
you become a member of this discord
server is by becoming a patron of new
rock stars so you have to become a
patron of our patreon it's just
something that we offer our patrons for
being so generous and kind and helpful
and supportive of this channel and our
growth is a way that you can just talk
to us in a way that we can hear from you
and like learn about you guys in your
lives and we can create like new ways
that we can like show our appreciation
for you somebody asked me on instagram
an idea and they're like I tried
messaging you a couple different places
this question and I kind of don't know
where to get an answer I was like
honestly if you're on discord yeah I'm
like probably gonna like give you a too
long of an answers
cuz there I can kind of like spend some
time and an Instagram be Emma on Twitter
or whatever it's kind of hard to you
know probe elongate any thought it might
be something about like discords
platform and I ain't I might bring this
up it sounds like I'm working for
discord to try to promote it but it's
just like the layout of it makes it
really easy for me to see like oh
there's this topic going on in like the
marble area so I'm gonna the marble
corner and see like what people are
talking about with like [ __ ] Winter
Soldier news and I'm going back to Clone
Wars do people talk about Colin tours I
forgot to get a drink earlier so if you
guys can just help me out what is this
have we been able to have imaginary
drinks I'm bringing my mug like a sucker
I have a question for you yeah
bitesize bite says I can I can handle a
bite sized alright
I've heard you rant on this topic before
and I kind of want to consolidate your
thoughts and just throw it at you so
this one's actually could just come in
from me okay bite-size question is and
in what ways is Disney about to take
over the world
[Laughter]
you have heard me thank you for
listening to my rants because yes this
is dreams we are in a fascinating time
with Disney's making a lot of big moves
and if you've been like reading through
the lines of like a lot of headlines
have come out recently you can see how
this thing is actually shifting the
whole filmmaking industry to a very
specifically this can be very profitable
for them
so last week Bob Shaye pick is now
taking over a CEO for Disney from Bob
Iger and while it seems like I don't
know what this means
Bob Shaye pig was head of Disney Parks
experiences in products unlike past CEOs
of Disney he doesn't really have a
background in film and TV I don't like
where this is going
well it actually could be something
really cool Bob Iger we used to be head
of paramount he was a filmmaking guy now
the company's becoming more about its
experiences so this is coming at the
same time that Disney just raised its
prices as ticket prices for Disneyland
to over $200 I really don't like oh yeah
this is also coming at the same time
where things like galaxy's edge are
redefining the Disney experience so
there's a cannon right it is cannon is
part of the Star Wars timeline of
narrative it's linked to the narrative
of the movies in this training series
that you watch and they're learning a
lot of lessons from Harry Potter
Wizarding World of Harry Potter through
Universal there are now shifting all of
their parks to being like cinematic
experiences that link to the movies you
watch in California Adventure it's all
Pixar up here so it's like you ride the
Incredibles ride and you're riding an
incredible story and an incredible story
of chasing down Jack Jack through what
used to just be a roller coaster and of
course Disney Plus is changing the game
in a lot of ways they're really just
entering this game to try to muscle up
against Netflix and they already own the
majority stake in Hulu but I think they
want to take over - straining content
world and then of course they own all of
Fox's properties and they own sony's
most profitable property which is
spider-man there they they co-owned it
they can get a lot of money for the
merchandising they can have fine
spider-man in their parks and in Disney
parks they're gonna be launching a new
marvel land and then the biggest one
that I think most people do not know
about because it's kind of confusing is
kind of inside baseball the paramount
ruling has been reversed by the Justice
Department let's talk about the
paramount ruling came out in 1948
it was in a lawsuit with the United
States about antitrust so basically what
at the time they decided is that film
studios cannot also own the way their
films are exhibited around the country
so that's why it's not a movie theater
they can't own a movie theater chain
that competes so they can't own all the
means of their production and make all
the money from it so that's why you have
things like AMC Cinemark arc light these
other movie take it's smaller movie
chains and they aren't like the
Paramount chain or the Fox chain or the
Disney chain or the Universal chain now
the Justice Department saying that's not
really necessary since people are
wondering how this is gonna change the
industry is it going to make it harder
for smaller film theaters to compete
because they don't have the financial
backing of the studios themselves
because currently the business model is
you go to AMC and really they make their
money from concessions and and other
kind of services they can provide you
can do AMC Stubbs and Dominion in the
back so how is this all going to change
why am i bringing this up well I think
what we're seeing now is movies are
changing they're becoming bigger
tentpole experiences and that's how
Disney's whole business models work
things like endgame and The Lion King
and their Pixar films are becoming
billion dollar movies and they're making
fewer and fewer smaller budget films
that are kind of what we considered to
be like normal movies things like knives
out which was like an original film
moderate budget made a decent amount of
money you don't see a lot of those
movies anymore and Disney is leading
this charge so I think by having someone
like Bob Shaye pick running their studio
that sends a signal to their
shareholders that they're gonna start
doubling down on their most profitable
line item which is parks they don't make
as much money from films because films
sometimes you lose a lot of money they
cost a lot of money to produce in the
market sometimes it's your margins on
that are that big I know this is all
basically like how does this all relate
to the way I experience movies basically
my prediction for the next 15 years is
you're gonna start seeing Disney
theaters in every major city and the
movies are exclusive the movies are
exclusive Disney movies so rather than
going to AMC and you can watch Sonic or
you can watch Star Wars or you can watch
knives out your
go to a Disney theater to where your
only options are a Star Wars movie a
Marvel Theory a Pixar movie maybe some
classic films that they're re-releasing
and those films are not gonna be just
simple films they're gonna be immersive
4d experiences that cost like 40 or 50
bucks because their whole idea is
spectacle and they realize that most
people now are sitting at home they're
watching streaming series they're
watching Netflix they're watching Disney
Plus I think they'll still release
normal movies on those platforms but if
they're gonna get you out of your house
it's gonna be like going to see Disney
on Ice or it's gonna be going to like a
smaller version of galaxies edge where
it's like not only are you gonna go
there and you're gonna experience this
movie there's gonna be associated
canonical games
you're gonna meet Ironman you're gonna
build a droid and it's all gonna be
linked with like the the narrative
experience and the only way you can
truly experience this MCU 10 or 15 years
from now will be to go to this Disney
theater and hopefully go to Disneyland
and Anaheim which is in Orlando once a
year to fully experience the AMC it kind
of there's a low fly crappy version of
it at the El Capitan right where you go
that's a Disney owned theater where
every movie release to show one big
movie at a time and the whole place is
decked out completely it's all cardboard
cutouts but with Disney budget maybe
it's actually interactive things that
like you have to solve on your way in
like a Dan Brown novel and people will
pay it I think that's the thing if you
can make it so that it is essential so
you don't have that fear of missing out
like they're gonna you're gonna some
diehard Marvel Star Wars I'll do it yeah
I would do it too and if you could just
say we're gonna require to do this four
or five times a year you make a lot more
money from those people than just having
those movies be ten dollar movies that
you have to share the profits with AMC
what's funny is in my head my
imagination started to go like more and
more advanced where it's not just a
projection screen in front of you the
side screens are also relevant the seats
you're in are like seats of this ship
whatever and then I was like and then
the actors they're not on the screen
they're there and slowly I created
theater just like really stupid like
costumes they're like yeah which it
might feel silly but imagine seeing a
movie but there's an Associated VR
experience it's a maze or an escape room
and in that way like it your environment
is part of your like the the walls come
alive and it's kind of like when you go
through galaxy's edge or when you go
through wits new world of Harry Potter
it's like an expiry
and to a lot of people that is far more
of an effective emotional thing a
satisfying experience than just like
watching a movie on a screen because
that can feel like oh I can watch this
song on any screen I can watch it on my
phone or I can watch it on my TV at home
so they're gonna have to start thinking
out of the box and how can we get people
to a space and charge them four times as
much let me throw a kind of makes it
they could you imagine don't breathe as
a movie going experience oh yeah where
you're like kind of like he's there too
and you have to kind of escape the
theater like a monster in the house and
your is breathing behind you or yeah
yeah you know it sounds terrifying also
are you saying that's within the next 15
years I think we'll start to see it in
the next I don't know if it'll take over
I'll say in 16 and a half years holodeck
that's really hard yeah well I've all of
holodeck holidays I'm calling it now I
think at some point our lifetimes the
term going to see a Disney will be a
thing as opposed to we go to see movies
right now it's gonna be like let's all
go to the Disney cool so that's Eric's
big Disney Theory for where it's all
going how their time it's the first time
I've heard you somewhat sober saying
that we have time to sort me out we've
done time for one more bite-sized
question this one wants to know what was
your worst there standing right behind
me aren't they
moments so that's you're talking [ __ ]
about someone or you're doing something
embarrassing okay when I'm at home yeah
that I can think of of like you're you
got caught talking [ __ ] all right uh-huh
I'm not I can talk about it though yes
you can this doesn't no one sees this
okay I used to work for a youtuber oh
this maybe we shouldn't tell me more it
was my first job in YouTube and your
popcorn there yeah I like pop glad I got
you soaked it was my first job in
YouTube and he or she was insane like
every youtuber all of them all of us
every single one of them is insane and a
crazy person cuz you're this job box
your mind up yeah you're right now you
have the exposure of a minor celebrity
but immediate access to feedback about
you that people would never say to a
minor celebrity like you don't go to a
person kind of like hey here's why
you're ugly and what you
wrong right and then also a DM telling
you that I hate you so you get all this
negative feedback but you don't have a
support system of like the studios and
hip agents and like don't worry those
are what you just like sit in your room
and read all that so he had really or
she had really gone down that path uh
and it made it impossible to work with
this person because it became so
obsessed with perfection
I actually suffered from a version of
this myself and to you hosting there's
no but but it does it makes you so crazy
and so everyone was just miserable
working there and then he or she had us
keep working on this one new pilot idea
it's great new comedy series and they
had a rewrite it again and again and
again and again and again and then they
started sending it out to I was like I
kind of ran things so I could see all
the correspondence and they started
sending out to all these other writers
right to sing again and again and again
and I got kind of sick of it at one
point I was bitching so my son's text
message to a friend that works there and
I was like can you believe this [ __ ]
you know this person is doing this thing
now I can't believe it I'm so sick of
this
yada yada uh and then I just looked and
I was like no I immediately sent it to
the youtuber because their name was
right there and I was like well if
that's the subject of my text I should
send it to that person so I just thought
like that's what I'm talking about so I
just sent it completely likes you know
stream-of-consciousness
directly to them oh and I just said and
waited for a bit I was like yeah that
wasn't to you I feel like at that point
you kind of like make it into a joke I
what if I really so died ya know but it
didn't work and then luckily everyone
was getting fired because the whole
company was being shut down and we had
already she had already fired like 15
people at that point so there was only
two of us left and so I got a call like
a week later and he's like well as you
know you know things are shutting down
so we have to let you go and I was like
oh cool no no worries no worries and
here she goes in the text message come
on it's like yeah I know but I got
caught hey but you know if they deserved
it one of the worst things you could do
is when you are 12 years old as I was
this
it was picture day at her school so we
normally I went to Catholic school we
had we were white polos navy blue pants
but on picture day you could wear nicer
clothes so I had a button-up shirt and I
never wore a button-up shirt so we're
changing for gym in the bathroom in the
boys bathroom and like I realized as I
was taking off my shirt I was like this
feels seductive I don't know it was like
we're all doing a bit where it's like
yeah another button-down another we're
all we were all I think everyone was
doing this it's so then as I was the
last one to do it of course because all
the other guys had done it and then I I
took it off and that last but I was like
okay well my my last one I really gotta
turn this into a fun thing so I took my
shirt I started like striptease spinning
over my head and then I saw the other
guys PJ Matt yeah squeeze in like Boyden
behind me and we'll immediately drop
their stuff and you know and then I was
like yeah right what and I turn around
and it's our gym coach coach al I won't
call you out but he goes he said his
whistle mr. Boz we've got a show going
on huh want me to bring the girls in
here is that what's going on bring my
boys in here I don't know myself yet
this goes down my leg working it in yeah
so that was and I will never take off my
clothes ever again never never nude
because of this story interesting so you
won't find me without a shirt on or
without pants on but I will put on more
clothes so send me clothes at RPI
honestly address down below if you send
it to me I will wear it ask it bad and
using extra-large yes but not adult
extra small I want to feel like a little
boy and this is our Neverland here at
little little new rock stars hey thanks
for joining us if you have any questions
send us at new rockstar
using the hashtag big question also you
can mail us at the address we've said
and we will read it on air we were just
having a discussion over whether we
should cut something that we saw in this
episode let us know the times what you
think it was just like how we were
wondering what the coronavirus storyline
wasn't talking Winter Soldier what that
also thanks for joining us subscribe to
new rock stars for breakdowns in
conversations that you are gonna get too
much information about follow Phillip at
Phillip Molina follow me at ei vas and
follow new rock stars on all social
media and make sure to follow the big
question as the podcast feed wherever
you get your podcast
see you next week folks bye
[Music]